[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soit il est bienvenu sur France 24 à la
une ce soir la justice britannique qui a
donné lundi son feu vert à l'expulsion
vers le Rwanda de demandeurs d'asile
arrivée illégalement au Royaume-Uni un
accord à condition que les situations
soient étudiées au cas par cas ce projet
reste très controversé la correspondance
à Kigali dans ce journal
abstention record en Tunisie depuis la
révolution de 2010 des législatives
boudées par une population lasse un
revers pour le président hors système
les détails dans ce journal enfin le
vaudou au service de la protection de
l'environnement alors que la COP15 est
parvenue difficilement un accord ce
lundi la religion traditionnelle est
devenue un allié pour protéger
l'environnement au Bénin et au Togo
reportage dans la réserve du delta du
mono à suivre dans cette édition
la Haute Cour du Royaume-Uni s'est enfin
prononcé sur ce projet très controversé
à la donnée son feu vert à l'expulsion
vers le Rwanda de demandeur d'asile
arrivée illégalement sur son territoire
une condition à toutefois été émise que
les dossiers soient étudiés au cas par
cas mais malgré tout de nombreuses
organisations internationales se
mobilisent contre ces déportations
jugées illégales par le HCR la
correspondance à Kigali de Clément di
Roma
le gouvernement rwandais affirme être
prêt à offrir aux demandeurs d'asile la
sécurité et une nouvelle vie après la
décision de la Haute Cour du Royaume-Uni
qui juge légal la déportation de
migrants vers son territoire les juges
ont cependant préciser que chaque
situation devait être examinée et que
les 8 premiers dossiers n'ont pas été
correctement traités alors c'est en
partenariat très important et très
controversé depuis sa signature en avril
dernier souvenez-vous en première avion
avait été empêché de partir pour le
Rwanda bloqué par la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme en juin à 2022 alors
les juges britanniques depuis septembre
ont entendu le Haut Commissariat au
réfugié de l'ONU et des organisations
internationales ces dernières estiment
que leur Ronda n'est pas un pays adapté
et sûr pour les demandeurs d'asile en
partie suite aux accusations de
violation des droits de l'homme alors le
gouvernement a réfuté évidemment et
affirme avoir déjà accueilli 130 000
réfugiés ces dernières décennies la
bataille judiciaire n'est pas terminée
la Haute Cour doit se prononcer en
janvier sur un possible appel et
d'autres procédures on pourrait être
déclenché devant la Cour européenne
enfin rappelons-le Danemark envisage
aussi de se lancer dans un projet
similaire avec le Rwanda
c'est le plus faible taux de
participation depuis la révolution
tunisienne de 2011 le scrutin de samedi
et boycoté par une majorité des partis
politiques un message fort au président
Kais
de législatives quand on vote c'est
prendre position quand on vote blanc
c'est prendre position et quand on
boycotte c'est aussi prendre position si
on regarde le taux d'abstention on
comprend que c'est un message fort de la
part de la Société du peuple à
l'intention des auteurs de ce processus
et de ce projet
depuis son élection en 2019 avec 70% de
votes le président Saïd étant peu à peu
ses pouvoirs
en 2022 il dissout le Parlement et cet
été malgré une mobilisation forte il
fait adopter une nouvelle constitution
qui réduit drastiquement les
prérogatives du Parlement
27% de taux de participation le pire
score depuis la Révolution jusqu'aux
scrutin de ce weekend
selon la Commission électorale le taux
est modeste mais pas honteuse mais pour
de nombreux partis politiques leur est
au changement
selon l'autorité électorale le taux de
participation est de 8,8%
nous considérons qu'il s'agit d'un
séisme de magnitude 8,8 sur l'échelle de
Richter seul 21 candidats ont obtenu un
siège dès le premier tour en deuxième
tour est attendu en début d'année
ce revirement pour Cyril Rama posa le
président sud-africain menaçait encore
la semaine dernière par une procédure de
destitution et désormais assurée de
faire un second mandat en cas de
victoire de l'ANC aux élections en
général en 2024 puisqu'il a été réélu à
la présidente de son parti la
correspondance au cap de Caroline Dumet
avec 579 voies de plus que son rival sur
plus de 4300 votants Cyril Rama posa
s'impose à la tête de l'ANC ce qui
pensait que l'affaire pas la Pala
l'avait discrédité bien ce sont trompés
il reste de loin le leader le plus
populaire du parti et si l'entame un
second mandat à la tête de l'ANC il
entamera aussi sans doute un second
mandat à la tête du pays si le parti
gagne les élections de 2024 donc ce
cette élection interne à la NCX est
cruciale car elle détermine les
personnalités qui vont gérer l'Afrique
du Sud dans les cinq prochaines années à
signaler d'ailleurs la présence de Paul
Machia Tilé l'ancien trésorerie est du
parti a été élu à la vice-présidence de
l'ANC ce qui signifie que s'il arrive
quoi que ce soit à Cyril Rama posa et
bien ça sera lui qui prendra la tête du
pays Paul machette donc un nom que les
Sud-Africains connaissent bien mais que
le reste du monde découvre aujourd'hui
en bref le parquet sénégalais a requis
l'indice deux ans de prison ferme contre
deux députés d'oppositions jugés à Dakar
pour avoir frappé une collègue de la
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale la
députée a mis Ndiaye qui s'est pris
entre autres un coup de pied dans le
ventre était enceinte son avocat a
déclaré qu'elle risquait de perdre son
bébé cet incident avait profondément
choqué le pays
la question des violences policières au
Kenya a fait l'objet d'une promesse
électorale trois mois après l'arrivée au
pouvoir de William Rousseau une grande
réforme de la police a été ordonnée par
le nouveau président une unité spéciale
mise en cause dans des exécutions
extrajudiciaires a été dissoute en
octobre les organisations de défense des
droits de l'Homme dénonce depuis de
nombreuses années ses violations
reportages anaérobie d'Élodie cousin et
de Bastien grenouille
c'est pas facile d'obtenir justice
surtout face à la police
l'état m'a dit que j'avais raison que je
devais recevoir environ 6 millions de
shillingénians
mais je n'ai jamais reçu cet argent
[Musique]
en août de nombreuses affaires de
meurtre impliquant des policiers ont
fait grand bruit le président a redonné
une réforme pour stopper les violences
mais sans donner plus de détails
j'espère qu'une partie de cette réforme
permettra de demander des comptes aux
agents de sécurité et plus
particulièrement aux officiers de police
ils doivent remplir leurs fonctions
comme le prévoit la Constitution kenyane
nous sommes tous des citoyens
respectueux aucun d'entre nous n'est
au-dessus de la loi il n'y a pas de
raison que cela soit différent pour les
forces de l'ordre un groupe de travail
doit être nommé par le président pour
aboutir à un changement réclamer depuis
des années par les ONG
la clôture de la COP15 pour la
biodiversité le pays du monde les pays
du monde entier ont adopté ce lundi un
accord historique à Montréal pour tenter
d'enrayer la destruction de la
biodiversité de ses ressources après
quatre années de négociation 10 jours et
une nuit de Marathon diplomatique plus
de 190 états sont parvenus à un accord
sous l'égide de la Chine présidente de
la COP15 et pour protéger la
biodiversité au Bénin on fait appel au
vaudou dans la réserve de biosphère
transfrontalière de du delta du mono la
religion traditionnelle est devenue un
allié pour protéger l'environnement
cette réserve à cheval sur le Togo et le
Bénin s'étend sur près de 350 000
hectares et vous allez le voir depuis
plusieurs années des ONG écologistes se
sont associés au chef dignitaire vaudou
pour défendre la nature reportage des
manuels soggi et de Rafael
au sud-ouest du Bénin dans la tradition
quand on ne voulait pas que les
populations s'approchent d'une zone on y
implantait une divinité pour protéger
une ressource rare
une ONG de défense de l'environnement a
eu l'idée de renforcer cette
particularité culturelle objective
protéger cette terre de conservation de
la bouche du roi qui a subi une
dégradation avancée de la biodiversité
cette population ici qui a une
population de pêcheurs pas cher beaucoup
de poissons et donc il fallait fumer le
poisson avant de vendre donc les femmes
allaient couper le bois de mangrove pour
pouvoir fumer le poisson les femmes
allaient également couper le bois de
mangrove pour préparer le sel cette
pratique ont dégradé sérieusement la
mangrove tout cela aussi aux effets des
changements climatiques a fait
disparaître 30% de la mangrove des lieux
de reproduction pour les poissons et de
nombreux animaux marins depuis 6 ans les
dignitaires vaudou et les représentants
des villages collaborent pour la
préservation de la biodiversité
nous surveillons tout le temps la
mangrove car nous savons qu'elle protège
notre côte de l'érosion et protège nos
villages elle limite les effets
désinondations elles permettent aussi
aux oiseaux migrateurs de venir pondre
leurs œufs
l'association communautaire qui regroupe
17 villages entre grands propos et
comète a déjà réalisé une quinzaine de
sacralisations désormais qui compte se
rend sur des lieux sacralisés comme
celui-ci à faire un embêtant une
divinité gardienne des lieux très
redoutés dans la région
si on attrape quelqu'un on l'emmène ici
sur la place publique pour le
sanctionner
[Musique]
que 10% de toute la mangrove mais des
résultats sont déjà visibles comme c'est
îlot reboiser et sacralisé il y a 7 ans
les oiseaux migrateurs ils sont revenus
il reste encore 3500 hectares de
mangrove un restaurer pour revenir à la
situation d'il y a 30 ans leur
sauvegarde est essentiel pour atténuer
le choc des changements climatiques et
assurer une économie durable aux
populations locales
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'Afrique restée avec nous l'info
continu sur France 24
[Musique]